okay so we've been talking in the
context of the 2020 Democratic primary
about this issue of should convicted
felons have the right to vote after they
have done their time and should they
have the right to vote while they are
still in prison and this is all part of
a broader movement that exists on the
American right to make it more difficult
for people who are likely to vote for
Democrats to vote we've seen this
targeting poor people we've seen this
targeting minorities we've seen this
targeting individuals on the basis of
the perceived or known political
orientation of particular parts of the
country and most of the left seems
United about the fact that eventually
felons should get the right to vote at
some point but it has become more of a
discussion as to whether people who are
in prison whether people who are still
whose freedom is still being kept from
them should have the right to vote so we
did a poll on the David Pakman show
community tab yesterday and I want to
share the results with you now because
they are very very interesting
forty-nine percent of the 15,000
respondents say that convicted felons
should have the right to vote while in
prison whereas 43% believe that
convicted felons should get the right to
vote back once their prison time or
parole or probation has ended so what's
overwhelming is that 92% of our audience
does believe that at some point convicts
should get the right to vote but there's
disagreement over whether it's while in
prison or not now I think there's a real
discussion to have about serious violent
criminals who are in prison without the
possibility of parole okay if you have a
serial murderer with no chance of ever
being in society again because they're
in prison without the possibility of
parole maybe you can make the case that
they shouldn't have the right to
influence a society in which they will
not be participating ever by voting that
may be the case but it's a mistake to
start there and that's why it was a
dirty trick to say to Bernie wait wait
and you're okay with the Boston bomber
voting because the reality is not about
the Boston bomber or Timothy McVeigh as
the most important thing if you're in
prison for marijuana possession which in
some places is criminal in some places
is a civil infraction in depending on
the state should you not be able to vote
because you're in prison for marijuana
possession if you stole a television and
later were caught with pot and you're
now a repeat offender and you're in
prison I'm fine with that person voting
I don't believe that that justifies
taking away a right that so many people
worked so hard to obtain and is a key
part of being a participant in society
you very quickly realize when you
actually start going through the
scenarios that most people in prison
should have the right to vote so we
shouldn't start with the edge cases or
the worst cases like should the Boston
bomber get a chance to vote should
timothy mcveigh if he was alive and in
prison get a chance to vote we shouldn't
default to take voting rights away from
everyone in prison because there are
murderers without the possibility of
parole and they really shouldn't be
voting well maybe if you have no
possibility of parole you're not allowed
to vote but most people in prison are
not murderers and I would actually go
even further
I believe that letting imprisoned
Americans vote has positive
externalities getting people involved in
the political system is going to reduce
the percentage of people that go back to
prison for crimes the more involved you
are the more you have something not to
lose hope over the more you have
community the more you feel like you
have a stake in what is going on around
you the less likely you are to commit
crime and that's why I'm fine having the
debate about should everyone in prison
get to vote I understand that some of
these more extreme cases maybe the
answer is no but most people who are in
prison should have the right to vote
particularly when you consider why many
of those people are in prison to begin
with one of today's David Pakman show
sponsors is east or built who's giving
everybody in our audience 20% off when
you go to East or built calm and use the
promo code
Pakman and this part is awesome they're
also giving a portion of each purchase
to Planned Parenthood and the ACLU if
you've been thinking about starting your
own online store or upgrading the one
you have checkout eStore built it's a
full-service set of solutions they offer
fully customized websites for your
webstore instructional materials for
improving your webstore low-cost
accounting services for your webstore
one web store created by e store bill
was just recognized by beheading calm as
one of the top 25 best web stores of
2019 East store built has team members
specializing in everything from Shopify
to social media marketing they can help
your business establish as an LLC which
is a great way to help protect your
business from fraud and lawsuits their
team of certified public accountants can
take care of all your bookkeeping your
payroll your electronic timekeeping and
provide other accounting consulting
their accounting team is headed up by a
certified management accountant with
experience managing business budgets of
over 75 million dollars just go to East
store built calm I've put a link under
this video use promo code Pakman at
check out PA k man2 get 20% off your
entire order of e store startup products
and materials and if you're interested
in their affordable professional
accounting services just get in touch
with them using their website contact
form tell them David Pakman sent you and
you'll get 50% off your first month of
accounting services when you sign up for
a year subscription and don't forget
that they'll give a portion of all
purchases to Planned Parenthood and the
ACLU